i bet you make a lot of people unhappy
uh yeah i don't know i think
maybe my writing makes people
uncomfortable but i think on a daily
basis i get on pretty well with people
sometimes
have you gotten any backlash for
anything you've written yeah i got a
couple of mean emails i think i think
one one of my friends was very upset
with me but you know i just had to
explain to her that these are just facts
you know it's i'm just recording this
stuff right i'm not i'm not trying to
like can i can i swear on your podcast
yeah yeah yeah i'm look i'm not trying
to shut on you i'm not trying to ruin
your day or anything
this is just what the numbers indicate
and
it is what it is right
and it's fair and like reporting
statistics too
is one thing it doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be outliers so people
don't have to particularly get offended
right because it's like no on average
this is this is life right this is what
it looks like i'm sure you get the same
as well right i'm sure you talk to
groups of people and they're just not
happy with what you have to say but it's
just
this is the reality in which we live
right we can't we can't go left or right
[Music]
welcome to episode 146 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
in this episode i spoke with vincent
harnam about modern dating pickup
artists and some terrifying statistics
on gender dynamics
vincent is a data scientist and law
enforcement consultant he completed his
phd at cambridge where he currently
teaches
i asked him several questions like what
do women want vincent what do men want
is a higher iq beneficial for
relationships what are some other
factors that affect relationships like
divorce being 50 percent more likely for
women who out earn their husbands
and what really is a simp we also talked
about the red pill nerds the manosphere
risk taking only fans and geeks
please subscribe if you enjoy this
episode before we get started this
episode was brought to you by nordvpn
nordvpn hides your ip and lets you
access forbidden parts of the internet
wanna buy new tropics from china
nordvpn
kidding don't do that probably listeners
outside the us know how much bigger the
netflix catalog is here
suckers now i'm in america and this
immigrant can access your netflix but
while traveling i still use nordvpn you
probably know nordvpn is the fastest vpn
in the world it doesn't buffer or crash
like others i've used but you may not
know all the ways it can protect you too
phishing sites or malware sites for
example are only getting better even
companies like facebook twitter linkedin
get hacked routinely
those of you who've manually changed
passwords for over a dozen accounts
understand the pain nordvpn works across
all your devices to protect you from all
those threats and more they're hands
down the best vpn in the game
if you haven't tried them already now is
the best time to start take advantage of
my exclusive limited time offer today
and see what full online protection
really feels like grab your nordvpn deal
today over at nordvpn.com
tmpp
or use promo code tmpp like the mckayla
peterson podcast for 61 off their
premium plan and their anti-malware
feature all with nordvpn's 30 day money
back guarantee
nordvpn.com
tmpp or code tmpp i hope you enjoy this
episode
[Music]
vincent haranam welcome to my podcast
hey michaela thanks for having me really
appreciate the invite
this is gonna be fun it's nice seeing
you again i think the last time i saw
you i was in the uk
absolutely it's been it's been quite a
while that was uh november i remember
correctly
that was november yeah it was a great
couple events we put on here in
cambridge and across the uk your dad was
a fantastic
yeah it was really fun okay so before we
get into things um can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do sure well i am a law
enforcement consultant and a data
scientist i also teach at the university
of cambridge
you know really honestly i'm just a guy
that likes numbers i think that's
probably the easiest way to put it
aside from that there's really nothing
else i just together likes uh applying
statistical and mathematical acumen to
understand social phenomena
okay how does law enforcement and data
scientists how do those two things
intertwine
law enforcement what did you say yeah a
law enforcement consultant and a
database yeah okay
so you have to imagine that there's a
lot of crime data out there a lot of
police organizations have quite a bit of
data that they need analyzed and
i have the ability to do so so they
would they would give me a data set or a
specific problem that they want me to
work on
and i would leverage a set of
statistical models in order to provide
an answer or give them some sort of
leverage with the data so
in essence it's it's them providing some
data me saying well these are the
results that i found and these are the
policy implications of these findings
okay interesting wow that's fun so it's
like actual truth right
here's the raw data
deal with it yeah exactly that you know
whether or not they choose to use the
data and actually implement changes a
different story altogether you never
quite know with uh with a public sector
organization what happens because
there's quite a bit of red tape uh there
are different stakeholders involved so
if it goes up the chain it goes up the
chain if it's not used it's not used
do you ever give people data that they
don't like they're like no that must be
wrong ah well
wrong in the sense that it doesn't quite
fit their world viewer and they're not
quite happy with the findings that
happens all the time
they think they get something but they
get the opposite
and uh they're typically not very happy
with me or with the findings themselves
but hey that's what it is it's the world
we live in you're not always going to
get what you want
this is true okay so what do you teach
at cambridge then do you teach data
science yeah in a matter of speaking so
i teach i teach a bit of statistics with
policing students here they typically
come for a masters of policing and i
typically work with them i have a number
of students that i that i work with as
well
but i'm mainly in the statistics stream
in dealing with with large data sets and
how to how to navigate your way through
it
cool okay i had to take statistics in
university did you like try really
um
it's hard to say
you like yes and no i think it was
second year so it was undergrad
statistics first or second year and i
was quite ill so i wasn't really going
to class and i think i got a d on
everything like i just didn't go
and then i nailed the final
exam and was like i should have just
learned everything first instead of last
i would have ended up with a higher
grade um so yeah i think i did enjoy it
but it's not
it's it's not like a humanities course
yeah yeah although i do think
i think that statistics is something
that should be taught to high schoolers
right from the very beginning
i i think that it offers a lot of
knowledge that is very practical so
mathematics is one thing right learning
algebra and math class is one thing but
being able to calculate a standard
deviation or an average helps you to
interpret the world better like you're
just able to look at certain phenomena
and say well is this an outlier or is
this an average and how how do i orient
my orient myself within that and you
know it in other words it helps you make
better sense of the world around you
hmm
did you hear i don't know if you've
heard but uh dad's been starting up
peterson academy it's launching in the
fall
yeah has anyone been
telling you you have you should you
should come teach your course if you
were interested in statistics you know
i'd love to make statistics cool i i you
know i i can't i've been told that i'm
i'm not a bad statistics teacher because
it's
i think that you have to get away from
the math and try to ground it within
within very practical practical uh uh
example
and i think people people gravitate to
it if they find that there's a practical
purpose or use to statistics
okay cool well we won't talk about that
now we'll be enticing about that i
appreciate the invite
okay sweet that's fun great
uh okay i'm gonna have some questions
about just things people might find
interesting
might might have to do with statistics
we'll see um you also have been writing
about modern dating no
so how does that get intertwined into
statistics and
it's a good question i get that question
a lot like what what is a data scientist
doing why is he why is he using all
these mathematical models to try to
understand dating and i i think the
simple the simple answer to that is that
well i'm just interested in the
phenomenon right i've uh you know i've
been on dates and i've dated myself so
why not actually try to understand it in
a more statistical way or a more
empirical empirical way and there's a
lot of data out there to to to work with
so i think that being able to apply
statistical principles data science to
something like this
helps people understand a very complex
phenomenon all i'm doing is simplifying
something that's very complex and i
think it gives people insight about how
how things operate
all i'm doing is simplifying something
very complex the dating world
relationships yeah okay
okay
um
in that case i've got some very specific
questions all right so
okay let's do it um
what do you think happens in a
relationship when
the woman out earns what the man earns
uh it's gonna end in divorce more than
likely so there's a study conducted
by american psychologists and they found
that if a woman outburned her husband it
was likely it was 50 likely that the
marriage would end in divorce in fact
this was corroborated by studies done by
finnish data scientists or
finnish
psychologists as well as swedish
psychologists and it's interesting
because the swedish psychologist found
that if a woman brought in 80 of the
total household income
there was a
the likelihood of divorce increased by a
factor of two relative to if one woman
brought in let's say 20 percent of the
total household income
wow
okay
so you said
so don't don't all relationships have a
50 chance of ending in divorce
yeah that's what that's what everyone
says or at least that's that's the uh
the idea out there uh i don't know how
well that statistic is stress tested
because
it's i think it's contingent on a lot of
factors so economics is a big one during
periods of depression people people are
economic downturn people typically don't
get divorced they typically stick
together because it's very costly
and as well you know there's a lot of
mediating factors that that
that
allow divorce to happen or make it more
likely to happen but economics is a
massive factor
specifically economics as in the wife
making more than the husband
so what's the solution there
i don't think there is a solution i
think that people should probably lower
their expectations and
in terms of in terms of understanding
that okay well this person is the
breadwinner and it's probably
whether or not it's a matter of the
woman that person is the breadwinner
it's just it's it's how the situation is
and one should probably temper their
expectations about that
okay that makes sense are there tricks
that you've heard of that you can do to
offset that so if you are the
breadwinner in a family and you're the
female is there something you can do to
offset the fact because it must be it
must have something to do with dominance
right you don't want to be maybe you
don't want to be the dominant person in
the relationship yeah yeah i think
it it's again it probably goes back to
roles played in relationships it's it's
not always the case that the man is the
breadwinner it's sometimes the case that
the woman is more dominant and she is
she is uh she is the breadwinner and so
it probably comes down to being able to
to met out responsibilities on the part
of both sexes and sometimes the man
stays home and takes care of children
and sometimes the woman goes out there
and earns you know earns the money and
so it probably is contingent on both
partners understanding that this is the
role that is played
okay
that makes sense
or they're just doomed or they're just
doomed
oh they're just doomed yeah
um
okay
you've talked about
dark gentlemen
what does that mean what's a dark
gentleman so a dark gentleman is a term
that i've
sort of coined to
describe the the perfect man as it were
or the man that is the most attractive
and the dark gentleman is a combination
of
a man that is able to provide 3p so he's
able to protect uh provide as an you
know economic provision and parentally
invest but at the same time he does have
those dark triad characteristics which
makes him very attractive so he threads
the line between the perfect gentleman
and that uh dark triad personality so
he's able to combine those two aspects
which are held in logical contrast so i
i refer to it as the unity of
contradictions it's actually very
similar to when your dad speaks about um
chaos and order i think he
the point that jordan is trying to get
across here is that you need a
combination of the two you need some
sort of golden mean as it were you can't
have too much order you can't have too
much chaos because in both situations
you get totalitarianism
yeah
that makes sense
so that would be i feel like the dark
triad too can you can you list off what
those characteristics are absolutely so
the dark triad are three personality
traits that are found in individuals so
you have machiavellianism which is
typically described as sort of
manipulation or the ability to
manipulate the second is narcissism you
know pretty straightforward and the
third is psychopathy so callousness
lying thrill-seeking so it's said by
psychologists that these three traits
are quite negative so individuals that
possess these traits are dark right
they're very
um negative individuals
yeah okay
and so
but for some reason they're attractive
to women yeah exactly that so these
aren't
evil but attractive yeah very very
attractive so these these individuals
it's important to keep in mind that
they're very low in neuroticism they're
very high in openness they're very low
in conscientiousness they're very high
in extroversion and
those characteristics on their own are
pretty attractive so a narcissist is you
know smile speaks nicely wears very nice
clothes you know that in and of itself
is pretty attractive to women right a
person that is machiavellian
is very disagreeable and what the
statistics indicate is that an
individual that is highly disagreeable
if if they
are below the the mean level of
disagreeability they typically make
eighteen point three percent more um in
terms of yearly yearly income and that
translates to about nine thousand seven
hundred and twenty two dollars per year
wow
how much of that is behind the wage gap
a lot a lot so
i think
agreeableness has to do quite a bit with
why some women don't advance as far as
they do in their in their fields in
their respective fields what men are on
average more describable than women so
they're more likely to fight for a wage
increase they're more than likely to
fight for
um a promotion
and so
these are this specific factor explains
why men typically you know earn women on
top of the fact that you know there's a
whole number of factors including
differences in in work and job type
occupation in in industry in schooling
in the amount of hours worked the level
of danger of the job itself it's one
factor among many i think
yeah that makes sense i didn't i've
always been like fairly have you ever
done my dad's personality test just out
of curiosity i have done a personality
test actually yes but not you have yeah
not quite your dad's
which one did you do i don't remember
but i do have it saved on my phone i
have the results saved somewhere
just from working for my dad and trying
to run a business and everything i've
had to kind of force myself into
uncomfortable positions and then you get
used to it right asking for more as a
woman
but i think a trick
for doing that is the worst thing that
can happen i got just to give you my
experience of like trying to ask for
more money or something is like i get
these like feelings of guilt and of like
do i deserve it am i doing enough like
this kind of thing even if kind of
logically i can say okay well if this
makes sense but it's like this guilt
horror feeling for asking for more
whereas if i talk to like disagreeable
men like
they're okay with asking for more even
if they don't necessarily think they
deserve it they're like i'm just gonna
see what happens and they're like well
the worst thing that could happen is
they say no yes so if you think about it
that way it's like what's gonna happen
if you ask for a raise they're gonna say
no like that's not that big a deal but
the feeling inside is like angst and
horror yes i think as a
female maybe at least me sometimes yeah
i i think i think a lot of women do have
that that specific experience i think a
lot of men are more comfortable asking
for a raise
uh
and you're right it's all it's all a
matter of opportunity and just taking
risks i think
a lot of the scientific literature would
indicate that women are more risk averse
than men men are typically the ones that
you know we talk about job type
occupation
they're typically the ones that do very
dangerous jobs right your your your data
will speak about um you know people that
work on oil rigs out in uh you know
various parts of the world specifically
in alberta and that's not that's not a
very safe job right it's quite dangerous
and it takes it takes a lot of cajones
to do a job like that you have to be
quite um
interested in risk or or very risk
oriented as it were
oh yeah that's for sure i've got cousins
who work on oil raised they're like
they're crazy people lose arms on those
things it's crazy yeah
uh yeah
okay
okay i've got some more questions from
things you've written oh okay let's talk
about this one this is fun um
why are smart women less likely to get
married
people above a certain iq that's a good
question so there was a study i'll add a
bit of context here so there's a study
that was conducted by four universities
here in the uk and it was on
um marriage and the role played by iq iq
affects marriage and what the study
found was that every 16 point increase
in a man's iq increases his odds of
marriage or his likelihood of marriage
by 35 percent
in contrast every 16 point increase in a
woman's iq decreases her odds of
marriage by 40
so you can see here that there's a
staggering imbalance right
and 40
40 a whopping 40
per 16 point increase
has there i do do you know if there have
ever been any studies on like do men say
you get somebody with 130 i have a 135
iq as a male
do we know the average iq they're
marrying like they can't be skewing
towards 100 right wouldn't you just get
honestly wouldn't there be a
communication issue if there's a two
standard deviation difference in iq yeah
more than likely more than likely i
don't know of any studies that would
indicate that but i think going back to
your original question as to why women
have
an issue particularly women within hike
you have an issue getting married is
that
they're looking for a person on their
same iq level their same their same
intellectual level and it's really hard
to find someone with that high of an iq
and these individuals are typically
probably in a lab somewhere or already
married and
for men as well i think a lot of guys
have an ego and they want to seem like
the smarter one in a relationship right
they want to see seem the most dominant
one and i think they're
they're they're put upon or they're
they're turned off by a woman that is
very smart right it's very it's very
emasculating
yeah that makes sense
well i mean that makes sense
fewer people out there and yeah
i mean i understand that i don't think
i'd want to be with somebody who i
thought was
dumber than me honestly be more
attractive if they're smarter than me
smarter than me like oh i didn't think
of that that's fun instead of being like
i've already thought of that
but thank you yeah we're trying
yeah i think you need a balance right i
think you need someone that is able to
sort of pick up the slack so there's
certain things that i don't know that i
would you know i love that my partner
knows and uh
in the opposite right i think it's yeah
it's that it's that balance as well that
you're able to balance one another
although i did have a friend and he
would always say that he had a very high
iq it was like 150 or something he would
say to me or i would ask him you know if
he did it go to 100 iq wouldn't as you
said wouldn't there be a communication
issue and he i think he said very
callously i have enough intelligence for
both of us and i said all right
interesting
okay i mean i can see that too i think
it's probably dependent on personality
too yeah i'm sure some people like maybe
your friend was just like it doesn't
matter i got it i have enough iq my
brain is good enough for both of us yeah
fair uh that's good
okay
well on on this point as well michaela i
just want to say that it it's also
down to preferences as well is that
women typically look for men who are
much smarter than they are right they
you know in terms of attractiveness the
two greatest predictors of a male
attraction as in female females being
attracted to males are educational
attainment and income and that's not the
same for males right the two
characteristics that males typically
typically look for are
youth infertility
yes harsh but true harsh for true
harsh but true
okay you said in an article
it's from my list of questions if
there's a disconnect between what women
want and what's actually available to
them
why do you think that is
um
it's it's a good it's a good question
and i think it's not just women i think
it's just it's just people in general
there's a level of entitlement that a
lot of people have and
what you think you get is not often what
you get in reality so a woman that is
highly educated woman that makes quite a
bit of money
uh on a yearly basis
you know she she in her mind and
probably rightly so deserves a partner
that that makes quite a bit of money and
has an equal level of education
but the trouble with that is that there
are few men who fit that certain
category who fit that criteria who can
reach that certain level and he is most
likely interested in a woman that is
much younger so although
you know the one feels that she can
attain this partner it's probably not
the case that she will be able to do so
so it's again it's that disconnect
between reality and perception
hmm
i bet you make a lot of people unhappy
uh yeah i don't know i think
maybe my writing makes people
uncomfortable but i think on a daily
basis i get on pretty well with people
sometimes
have you gotten any backlash for
anything you've written yeah i got a
couple of mean emails i think
one one of my friends was very upset
with me but you know i just had to
explain to her that these are just facts
you know it's i'm just recording this
stuff right i'm not i'm not trying to
like can i can i swear on your podcast
yeah yeah yeah i'm like i'm not trying
to [ __ ] on you i'm not trying to ruin
your day or anything
this is just what the numbers indicate
and
it is what it is right
yeah
yeah
that's good that sounds like fun
okay that sounds like fun and it's fair
and like reporting statistics too
is one thing it doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be outliers so people
don't have to particularly get offended
right because it's like no on average
this is this is life right this is what
it looks like i'm sure you get the same
as well right i'm sure you talk to
groups of people and and they're just
not happy with what you have to say but
it's just
this is the reality in which we live
right we can't we can't go left or right
yeah
i don't think i get that much
oh actually that's not true i'm gonna
bring this up the the most recent thing
i think i freaked out about on instagram
was this this leah thomas swimming
situation
and i was like okay i don't really care
what people do but that's starting it's
turning me into a feminist people it's
turning me into a feminist and i had one
of my friends from toronto messaged me
and they're like oh now you now you're a
swim expert
i was like excuse me
so yeah i don't know i i don't get too
much negative
attention most of most of it has to do
with my dad i think
i can imagine i think that that's a
double-edged sword right um having a
father as famous as jordan peterson has
his benefits but of course there's a lot
of drawbacks to that as well
yeah
yeah
i think i think in my family it's
different i think my brother like the
reason he's kind of stayed out of it
anything he's less extroverted than me
so that's probably the the main reason
but also is he doesn't doesn't want any
of the negativity that comes with it
because we did have a kind of chasm with
like friends splitting and it was
stressful but
i don't care obviously i like it
i enjoy it actively bring it on
troublemakers good mentality to have
this episode is brought to you by paleo
valley 100
grass-fed beef sticks i'm in miami
because i'm allergic to tennessee
long story we'll update on the next q a
so i don't have beef sticks to show you
but just imagine a pepperoni stick
but beef
these things are delicious according to
my brother and everyone else i've fed
one who comes over they come over i'm
like you want to be sick they take a
beef stick they enjoy the beef stick
they have zero preservatives or fillers
it's just 100 american 100 grass-fed and
finished beef from domestic regenerative
farms and organic spices they're a great
and super easy way to lose weight just
switch whatever snack you're used to
for beef sticks
paleo valley is unlike any of their
competitors they're committed to making
high-quality products free of
problematic ingredients and farming
practices that harm the environment free
of those practices their products come
from small family-owned farms right here
in the u.s and their cows are never fed
grains or antibiotics paleo valley's
mission is to create products that live
up to their own strict standards and
always prioritize health
over profit
for example they always insist on
nutrient density in an industry that
prioritizes everything else especially
in the us
they also acknowledge every dietary
choice and every added ingredient is an
opportunity to take care of ourselves
you can help your body and the
environment by trying paleo valley's
high quality protein today just head
over to paleovalley.com and enter code
mp for 15 off your first order that's
paleo valley.com with code mp for 15 off
your first order i hope you're enjoying
this episode
how have dating and the process of mate
selection changed say in the last 40
years
that's a good question so
we can take our parents as an example
how did your parents meet
they grew up next to each other and met
when they were eight well would you look
at that a local dominance hierarchy
right so they they lived next to one
another they probably saw each other
every day at school local bars that sort
of thing very much a local a localized
phenomenon the same thing with my
parents right they didn't they didn't
live next door as your parents did but
they live within close proximity
so
the modern dating marketplace is very
different in the sense that on one hand
we have the the globalization of the
sexual marketplace and collapse of local
status articles or hierarchies in the
sense that technologies like like tinder
or instagram make it so that you have
more viable partners from which to
choose from
i think that that is one significant
factor
other factors would include greater
variability among males so we talk about
pareto distributions and power laws you
have more guys that are are sort of
average or below average and a very
small percentage of men that make a lot
of money that are very well to do and
these men that are are more desirable
for women and as well you have a higher
level of female attainment a lot of
women are doing better relative to their
male counterparts and so that notion of
hypergamy so women marrying upwards
plays plays an important role here where
it creates a again a power law
distribution in the um in the dating
world where there's a very small
percentage of men that are desired by
the outside proportion of women
um yeah okay so those are not those are
problems but i don't know how to solve
them how do you feel about the current
like red pill kind of group of people
that's i think that's a fantastic
question and i actually thought you
would actually ask me that um
personally i
i
am not a part of that community i'm not
a member of the manosphere or whatever
they call it i'm not a joiner so i would
never i would never join any group
that's just not how i do things kind of
just the lone wolf but i would say that
there are some positive aspects to it so
i know royal tomasi was on your podcast
a little while back
and i i've read some of his work and i i
don't know him personally but i can say
that he's very thorough in what he
writes and there there is a bit of truth
to what he he he does right i think at
least looking at it from from from my
perspective you read the rational mail
yeah i i think that was that is one of
the foundational readings to to to do if
you're looking to write on on this topic
in in my in my opinion but while
that oh i've got wait i have a question
about that then sure um okay i was told
and i don't know whether this is true or
not but i was told that there aren't
actual
statistics or there isn't any
information behind the statistics in
that book
is that just wrong
is that book an accurate representation
i don't know if that's the case actually
i i remember that a lot of it because
it's been quite a while since i read
those books maybe
four years ago
i don't recall there being any a whole
load of statistics i do remember some
but it's more so logical arguments or
specifically some some anecdotal
examples um were presented
okay yes
but i suppose moving forward with the
question that you've asked i do think
that there are some positive aspects to
to the red pill in terms of you know for
men bettering oneself and engaging in in
a positive way when it comes to
romantic relationships
but i do think that there are some
negative aspects as well where it does
it does lead men to hate women in in
some respects right it does it does
generate that and i know there's some
youtube channels that cater to that sort
of thing
dunking on women that's her jerry
springer-esque
entertainment
so
that that definitely does play a role
within within the red pill community is
is a hatred of women instead of looking
at men and women as being equal but
different and playing specific roles
within within a relationship
and that one is not complete without the
other and that you need both to have a
healthy relationship and create a
healthy family
yeah that seems like a positive way of
talking about it i think i i'm i pretty
much agree with you like i can
definitely see benefits of and i know
people who have had benefits from being
in the red pill community or listening
to those videos where it's like i was
thinking about the world completely
wrong and now i can see it for what it
is but then there are people are like oh
now i see it for what it is
women are evil
yeah well that's that's a fantastic
point because it's just like any bit of
knowledge you receive right it's you can
go one of two ways with it you can look
at it in a very positive light and say
well i can use this to improve my life
and the lives of those around me or i
could take this knowledge and do a lot
of damage with it and
you know it's it's like with the pickup
community in the red pill space is that
are you using it to
better your
you know romantic prospects in the sense
of getting in in healthy relationships
or are you just looking to get laid are
you looking to to have as much vapid sex
as possible
yeah
exactly
couldn't agree more
um what's your goal like over the next
number of years like you're teaching at
cambridge what's your what's your life
plan my lifeline that's a good question
you know i never really talk about
myself i try to keep it specifically to
my ideas into my writing but just this
once michaela just for you okay okay
good i'll speak about my life goals uh
very vague and opaque very abstract uh
freedom and apotheosis so freedom i want
to be as free as possible i want to move
i want to do what i want what i want
with whoever i want and nice apotheosis
is just reaching the highest possible
version
being the greatest possible version of
myself
okay i like it
i feel like that's kind of how i feel
like i i want to do whatever i want
don't bug me about stuff make me do
things i don't want to do it exactly
yeah i'm not worried with other with
what other people are doing i'm not big
into social media i'm just really
focused on doing my own thing and you
know living my life one day at a time
and i look i have my goals as everyone
else does and i'm going to work towards
those things i'm not really interested
in in the fanfare or or the social media
stuff there's no there's no instagram
stories there's no tweets there's no
post on facebook it's just me doing my
thing
i'm gonna blow one of these
clips up
ruin your life
do you think there's anything that can
be done
about the current imbalance in the
sexual marketplace no like are they
think no that's it no that's that's just
no
i'm sorry to be negative but this is
just how it is again we're talking about
reality as it were
and i think that
this sort of phenomenon just plays
itself out
right um we're on a path that is is not
is not a recent thing right this has
been going on since the 1960s with the
invention of the birth control pill
and it's sort of it's it's metastasized
from that and it's it's 50 60 years in
the making and so naturally assuming
that there's a solution to this problem
is incorrect it has to play its way out
and i think
there is some positive here or at least
some some silver lining here in that
if you look at
um rates of crack cocaine usage in the
inner cities in the 1990s a lot of the
reason or a major reason why young
children didn't do crack okay is because
they saw the effect that it had on their
parents generation so i think that
successive generations will look at the
way the current dating marketplace is
structured and save themselves well i
don't want that sort of life and they
may just be able to learn from the the
examples set by their predecessors
i think that makes sense so do you think
there's going to be a resurgence then in
more traditional values yeah i would
think so because when when a system i
don't think people are done per se i
think that they are
under-informed or they
lack knowledge on a specific thing and
if presented with a requisite amount of
knowledge they're able to make the right
decision ultimately
and i don't think that's just at in the
individual level i think that is at the
societal level and if a lot of people
are very much aware of how the dating
marketplace is structured and the
deleterious effects of it they're more
than likely to restructure the way that
they go about engaging with
relationships with with the people
around them
i completely agree i think that's why
freedom of speech is so important too
because if you just let people have
information like we're smart enough and
say on average smart enough to look at
the information and then come to
conclusions if you have
all of the information right and not
just a subset that pushes you in one
direction right yeah right
right knowledge is incredibly important
and as you pointed out it's it's it's
it's the freedom to to have this
knowledge accessible and be able to make
decisions based off of that knowledge
whether or not you make a mistake or
make the right decision is irrelevant as
long as you're able to make the decision
the decision with the information
available is all that matters
yeah i agree
okay what are your thoughts on
only fans
i think it's a fantastic business model
i really do because it it you know in
one sense it it does capitalize on
something which is quite lucrative and
that's emotional connection a lot of
young men out there are not able to get
into a relationship for a variety of
reasons maybe they play too much video
games maybe they they don't really work
on themselves but only fans takes
advantage of this particular situation
and it it allows women specifically to
make quite a bit of money but of course
there are negative negative aspects of
it right again it's it's
it
it does deal in in
you know degeneracy in in some ways
right when one is selling not quite
selling their body but but engaging in
behavior that is not necessarily you
know conducive to building a healthy
society let's say
so
while i don't i don't necessarily blame
these women for the hustle
i i do think that it does represent a a
wound within society
that this sort of industry is very
popular although
you know prostitution is the oldest
profession as they say and while only
fans is not prostitution let's make that
clear
it is sort of a derivative
yeah do you think there's a type of
woman that can do that kind of work like
you said is not prostitution but it's
a derivative do that kind of work and
not have negative consequences later
just be like yeah like it was fine it
didn't bug me and it was something i did
when i was younger maybe and like
yeah and there are people that can
handle that certainly or do you think it
leaves a bad imprint period it does i
mean i think in in one sense i don't
know i can't speak on the psychological
aspect of it the emotional aspect of it
because i don't i don't know that
literature well enough i would assume i
would assume that it does
but i will say that you know the
internet is forever and
if an employer is able to look up your
internet history and see that you've had
an only fans page
maybe they'd be less inclined to give
you a job maybe
this is true
yeah
yeah that's terrifying yeah
the internet is forever that's
terrifying
how would you this is this is fun how
would you describe what being a simp is
for people who don't know what that
means ah okay that's a good question so
a simp is a
uh transcended nice guy he is the type
of guy that placates to a woman that
pedestalizes her and
engages in in you know undo praise and
gives gifts for the sake of receiving
emotional connection and sex so there is
no emotional connection there is no
genuine interest in a woman he's simply
doing it because
praising her and giving her gifts
because he wants something in return
so simp is it
i think within modern parlons it's it's
used to describe a male that is
subservient
wow that might have been the best
definition of a symp that i've heard
thank you that was yeah i always thought
that totally makes sense too i always
thought it was kind of
a man who's
probably more agreeable
and
is is being nice out of guilt or
something but you think it's just a
direct transaction it's do things nice
to receive
sex basically yes it's it's creepier
yeah for sure i think it's machiavellian
nature and i think the term actually is
very related to the sneaky [ __ ]
syndrome so this is used to describe
yeah yeah you know fish and specific
animals in the animal kingdom
that are not able to cut it so they're
not able to reproduce with with females
of of that specific species so they'll
look for very sneaky ways to impregnate
the species so male gobi fishes
as an example uh the ones that are
smaller are not able to to reproduce to
fertilize eggs the larger male gobi fish
are able to do so so the smaller ones
will either hide or disguise themselves
as females and when the males are away
they'll sneakily
fertilize the eggs
that's hilarious
that's hilarious how does that kind of
thing even evolve it's not like these
fish can think right now like i better
better decide i'm a female now just
screw over this big guy yeah you know i
think you touch on an important point
here because i think it's all instinct
and it's not only just in among animals
so goby fish but also uh human beings
and there's a natural instinct to
reproduce and
you'll look for as many strategies or
try as many strategies as you can and
you'll find the one that works best and
maybe simping is that option that a lot
of people have i wouldn't recommend it i
mean if one applies a bit of game theory
as i've done in a paper you realize that
it's it's not it's not conducive to
being able to have a long-term
relationship you'll probably get played
wow okay
so there's a couple questions from that
um
what do i want to start with that's
scary so you said
i did i never i never actually thought
about that kind of behavior of like a
simp as
machiavellianist
like so you suggested that there's like
danger there ish
in a sense i i think that it is not born
out of good intentions that there's a
level of manipulation involved which i
think is the standard definition of what
it means to be machiavellian is to be
manipulative and so it's you're not
you're not engaging with a woman out of
necessarily a love for her that is that
is you know that is pure and that is not
that is not based on any sort of um
negativity it is more so that you are
engaging with her
uh in order to receive something in
return which is sex or maybe even
emotional connection so there's no
there's no genuine genuine desire for
this person
beyond beyond a base desire to have sex
this is why i don't trust agreeable men
that makes sense
okay you mentioned game theory
so can you describe what that is i don't
know if i'm familiar i feel like i've
heard that and i've never actually
delved into it yeah so so game theory is
a branch of economics or mathematics
that deals with how rational actors uh
engage with one another so the idea
behind game theory is that there's
there's two or three precepts where you
have a set of rational actors they all
have a set of strategies that's the
second thing and the third thing is that
you can measure the outcomes of these
strategies so the prism dilemma is is
one such example of game theory it's
very popular example of of um two
individuals
are you know they're
on the cusp of being convicted for
murder and they have one of two options
which is snap snitch on the other person
or remain silent to not snitch and we
can kind of measure the outcome of
actions taken by either individuals
how do you do that
well the two possible options that each
individual has is as i said snitch or
remain silent and there's a payoff
matrix that is attributed to all these
all these all of these decisions and the
payoff matrix typically involves years
in prison so if both people were to
remain silent
you know you might serve one year in
prison the two of them if one snitches
and the other one doesn't well the other
one gets off scot-free and the other one
goes to prison for let's say
10 years
if both snitch on the other well both go
to prison for five years so you're able
to measure the potential outcome of all
these all of these decisions that are
made by both actors
cool
okay i feel like i learned this kind of
thing in statistics
yeah yeah
okay okay that's cool i'll take your
your peterson academy statistics course
statistics is fascinating i thought it
was fascinating and then you can read
papers and when it says something like
one standard deviation you're not like
i'll just skim over that yes yes i i
completely agree i think there needs to
be a base as i said a base level of
knowledge that the average person has on
statistics because it allows them to
interrogate data it allows them to
interrogate findings so they hop upon
because
i think that there's a lot of chicanery
and [ __ ] that a lot of social
scientists engage in when they conduct
these studies it's the primary reason i
think why we have replication crisis in
the social sciences is that you have a
lot of social sciences that social
scientists that don't do a very thorough
job in the way they conduct these
statistics so if the average person were
to be able to read these statistics
cogently and understand what is being
presented and the methods being used
they'd be better able to interrogate the
findings and decide for themselves
whether or not the findings were
accurate or not
do you think that's
useful also if you're not a nerd no
offense or anything i'm a nerd too but i
mean for like the average person is it's
still useful if you're just reading
mainstream media articles or just
anything definitely definitely and in
fairness i'm a geek so i think chris
chris wilson and i had this really
odd discussion about it and i got a lot
of flags from people about being geek or
a nerd we don't have to go what what
what's the difference between a geek and
a nerd okay well i sorry you started
it's okay it's it's true i did start it
so a friend of mine james orr i think
you're familiar with james yeah his
daughter honor orr uh wanted to
find out whether or not um
an insult for her brother was the most
accurate but she couldn't decide whether
or not he was a dork a nerd or a geek
and she's like you're a math guy sit
down and figure out the difference
between these two things and you know i
actually sat down and tried to
categorize them in very in a very
particular and accurate way it's amazing
yeah so what i did was that i created a
a hierarchy and it's based off of
requisite characteristics so a geek is a
person that has function you functional
utility and intellectualism so you can
think about a coder someone like elon
musk for example all right they actually
provide a product that people can use
you know tesla for example
and there's there's a bit of
intellectualism involved because you
know there's some coding there's some
numbers there's some math
and that's what a geek is now a nerd is
a person that
has intellectualism that lacks
functional utility so you can think
about a person that studies 18th century
poetry or like 14th century russian
literature or something it has no impact
upon society at large like the average
person doesn't benefit from it but there
is that level of intellectual rigor
and a dork has neither there's no
intellectual
you know rigor or any function utility
and it's not to say that you can be just
one or the other you can fit in all
categories i mean there's certain things
i like that are entirely nerdy or dirky
they're dorky
that's hilarious
so then
would you assume that most people who do
some sort of science are
they're geeks but yeah people in the
humanities yeah are they also geeks or
are they exactly that exactly that so
the benefit of being cambridge is that
you run into all these people all the
time and
a lot of my friends are in the
humanities and i refer to them as nerds
and they say that oh you're not a nerd
you're not a nerd you do math all day
i'm like yeah i'm a geek i'm not saying
that i'm not i'm better than you guys
i'm just saying that there's a diff
there's a there's a minute difference
between what you do and what i do
mine is useful and you're a nerd yeah
exactly
i solve crap that's you read poetry
that's hilarious
okay so do you actually help solve crime
well i i just help provide insight and i
train i train law enforcement um
i train analysts and and police officers
so at some point down the line yeah i
would say so that i help to equip
individuals with methods that they can
use to help solve crime or help police
organizations allocate resources better
wow that's pretty cool
how long have you been doing this for is
this new yeah about a year and a half i
mean i'm fresh out of a phd so i've been
i've been doing this it's my job
so you grad and you graduated from
cambridge and then immediately started
teaching yeah
wow
that's pretty impressive thanks
what do you think men want in a woman
when men wanted a woman that's a
fantastic that's a vague but like
it's a great question because i was
actually thinking of writing a
it's probably not going to happen
anymore but i was thinking of writing a
two-part series on what women want and
what men want so two distinct papers and
i think again going back to to
what men want i think youth infertility
are two big things
but i think at a very base level men
want infection they want to be loved and
they want to be respected i think that's
what they're looking for in
relationships i mean
you know there's a number of other
things that i think are important i
think loyalty is incredibly important as
well i think men are also looking for a
level of femininity they're looking for
value compatibility having the same sort
of values and beliefs
um
collegiality i think is a big one as
well whether or not you get along with
your partner but again these are general
things i don't think they're necessarily
about what men want specifically i think
both genders or both sexes would look
for that in the opposite sex
what do you think women want what do i
think that's gonna be part of the paper
right yeah yeah i mean
look uh
hypergamy is a big part of it right a
woman wants a man that makes x amount of
dollars is his tall is uh you know
socially calibrated has a good social
network but those are all sort of
physical things right they're all very
tangible but
at the same time she's just really
looking for protection and uh and safety
i think loyalty is a big part of it as
well uh
trust affection that sort of thing you
know we're all animals at the end of the
day and
although we are different sexism
in that sense
we are all after the same sort of thing
yeah i think that's important for people
to remember too because there's a lot of
talk i know in the more like probably
more conservative circles like the
differences and everything
and then in more liberal circles it's
like it's the same yeah but yeah what
would you say though you know if i were
to ask you what do you think men are
after
oh man i don't even i don't know okay
just like from my experience and like
having male friends and talking to
people um
i don't think you're off by
like respect for sure you don't want to
be with somebody who doesn't respect you
so then there's no attraction there
right so respect and then i would say
most people want love and affection
like life is pretty hard to do by
yourself even if i think even for people
who don't have a hard life it still
kind of sucks to do by yourself so
you're looking for love and affection
and that probably comes
more for men with
respect
um
i'd probably put those three and then
for women
i think you're probably right about that
too feeling safe is a big one as soon as
you don't feel safe it's like i suppose
you can carry that on for a while
because it can be exciting yes a little
bit but i mean that's not long term like
you want to feel safe but not bored
yeah
i think it's safety safety and security
and those aren't necessarily the same
things right um safety is more of a
physical thing and security may be an
economic thing and it can also be an
emotional thing as well where you're you
feel safe being with this person in the
sense that you can tell them anything
yeah
do you think that goes for men too do
men care about that as much like i think
women i think too because women are
probably more prone to negative emotion
you know on average and more agreeable
that if you get a negative response from
someone if you're like oh this is
something i did or this is how i feel
and then you get a negative response
from that i know my reaction is to be
like
maybe i should just avoid that topic and
i'm pretty disagreeable for a woman and
i still get i mean so maybe that's just
how people react
yeah
i think certainly at least in in my case
i'm i'm more than happy to have a
difficult conversation i'm more than
happy to rip the band-aid off and just
talk about something despite it being
very uncomfortable i think that's that's
important in relationship regardless of
whether or not it's romantic
you have to be able to communicate and
have very difficult conversations i
think
regardless of whether or not you're a
man or a woman is just it's just a good
quality to have in a relationship
yeah i completely agree i know as a
woman it's easier if your partner
doesn't freak out
yeah like if you're like this is a
problem and they go ah then you're like
whoa okay
maybe that's a touchy subject that's a
little scary so yeah i think that's just
good to have in a relationship is hey
can we talk about things
under the assumption that we're going to
both work on fixing them yeah rather
than being mad at each other and just
sort through them so we don't have to
deal with this forever definitely i
think a good question here and i wonder
i wonder what you think is that
what are some of the things that you you
would say are are
characteristics that would define a
healthy relationship or things to have
characteristics to define a healthy
relationship
well like i said i think
feeling safe is important especially for
the woman and i think if you feel safe
you're more likely to bring up difficult
topics so you're like this is what's
bugging me or i think we need to work on
this if you feel safe then you can bring
those up but if you don't feel safe
you're not going to be able to bring
those up right and then
honesty
for sure like um i i think one of the
difficulties i've had with relationships
is
not saying things that need to be said
and especially when i was a like it's
different i'm 30 now so i'm just it's
just different now but like 22 or
something when i ins if i didn't talk
about something that was going on i kind
of thought it might go away and that's
having my dad as my dad
telling me from when i was a kid being
like you have to say things you have to
tell the truth yeah but i was like well
if i don't say something is that lying
like not really but it turns out it
doesn't go away right
so yeah it's tricky what do you think
yeah i i would say that
communication we discussed that i think
is a very important element you have to
be able to communicate with your partner
i would say that kindness is incredibly
important i see this on a lot of
relationships where people are just not
kind to their partner i don't understand
it because your dad actually speaks
about this where he says that
kindness is important because you don't
want to put the other person down
because it it creates an imbalance in
the relationship this person is looking
to get back at you
and you devalue that person so you're in
a relationship with a person that is now
lowered because of your actions so
kindness is incredibly important
i would say that space is important as
well i think
you are yes you're one unit but you're
also individuals and it's important to
be able to do your own thing and have
space and not have to be totally reliant
on the other individuals be clingy
and finally i would say
presence is also important as well
you'll go to you know i'll go to
restaurants and i'll see couples with
one another and one person is on their
phone or both people on their phone
they're not engaging with one another
and i think that it's just important to
be with the person and be completely
present when you're there
okay that was more succinct than my
version
for
for kindness
too
i think there's there's probably usually
some problems behind there like if
you're being mean
why would you be mean to someone that
you're with right and if you're trying
to bring up a sensitive topic like yeah
be nice about it
that's reasonable
be kind yeah yeah be kind i think it's
no one likes a dick right just in
general just don't don't be a dick to
people and and people will return in
kind
yeah
and you mentioned space so did you
remember with your personality test did
you come off as you must be fairly
disagreeable oh my god yeah i scored
pretty pretty pretty uh pretty low on uh
agreeable
okay i feel like i can just hear that in
your voice that's good i like i get
along with disagreeable people i feel
like you can trust not to like
denigrate agreeable people because
but i feel like you can trust
disagreeable people because if you
remove the emotions then they're just
gonna tell you what the truth is rather
than
lying very true very true i think you're
right about that so a group of people
they just they go along to get along and
they're the type of people that tell you
what you want to hear as opposed to what
you need to hear
because they'd rather not rock the ball
right again they're just they're
completely agreeable and a disappear
disagreeable person doesn't give a [ __ ]
just tell you how it is
yeah you're doing i'd rather have i'd
rather have friends that would tell me
what i needed to hear as opposed to what
i wanted to hear and i think i think
that is that is incredibly important
i bet though i know when i was um i used
to have really severe depression i was
on medication and everything and when i
was like that when i was depressed um
it was way harder like to hear things
that hurt my feelings and and also
interestingly i was very concerned about
hurting other people's feelings so that
was when like i said i was younger and i
was like maybe i shouldn't talk about
this because i don't know if it's going
to hurt the other person's feelings yes
right and i it bothered me like actively
physically
made me anxious hurting somebody else's
feelings
and now that i'm honestly now that i'm
healthier um and i like i said i don't
mean to denigrate agreeable people but
now that i'm healthier it doesn't
i don't have an emotional reaction
to necessarily telling somebody the
truth even if it hurts their feelings
like you don't go out of your way right
be kind but it doesn't like
i don't have the angst associated with
it like i used to yes yes and
you're right so i i would say that it's
also a matter of how you say things
because being disagreeable could be
could be
you conveying a truth but how you convey
that truth also matters so instead
selling instead of telling your friend
dude you [ __ ] suck you're horrible
you can instead say you're not quite
doing this correct um you know have you
thought about doing it this way so it's
it's how you how you present the idea
that it matters just as much as what the
idea is
that's a good point
that's a good yeah that's a good point i
should probably bring that up to some of
my more disagreeable friends too because
i have some people and they're so
disagreeable they're like who cares
right they look literally at the point
where they're like well it's the truth
so who cares why are you hurt it's the
truth it's like
you didn't have to just slap them with
it right right you're not going to win a
political campaign just on on faction
logic alone you're going to have to be
able to show some part right it's about
hearts and minds
yeah definitely
and you mentioned space too i'm so
extroverted like and that's not even a
good creeple because like i said i'm not
particularly agreeable but i'm so
extroverted that i don't want to be by
myself at all like the reason i started
the entire podcast was because i was
like
stuck at home in canada during lockdown
and i was like i need to talk to people
like i can't do this right i can't be
like by myself i feel like when i'm in a
like a
good relationship i'm currently in a
good relationship thank god but
i don't want to be by myself at all and
i don't i feel like space doesn't exist
for me i think it's an extroversion
thing like i could just be doing my own
thing but as long as i'm right next to
somebody else
right
i like parties where i'm able to leave
like i i i'm like serious like i'm happy
i'm happy hanging out with people
you know when when i want to but i need
my space i need to be able to work and
do my own thing and just have a bit of
head skills so i would say that you know
you need to have a bit of balance with
the two at least at least from my
perspective
i i do i i did score very high in terms
of extraversion but at the same time i i
am a very private person
you know i keep things to myself or at
least i have i have someone that i speak
to about those things
and um you know that that's that's just
me just prefer a bit of privacy
i do not apparently
i was always like that though i had a
roommate in university too and i was
like she was i don't know what but we
literally like for a while slept in the
same bed it wasn't a sexual thing but it
was like you're going to bed in the
other room i'm in the bed in this room
and we can't talk to each other so like
right that seems silly couldn't you just
pull up a chair or something
um yeah probably we didn't so did you
say you're not planning on finishing
that written piece i feel like that
written piece could be popular no it
probably will be popular but the thing
is is that this whole public
intellectual stuff i just do it for fun
i mean i'm not trying to sell anything
to anyone i'm just doing it out of it
really out of intellectual curiosity and
trying to yeah
inform people on something that i think
is important and that could potentially
be a problem down the line and the issue
with that is that there's a lot of
things that i'm working on on a daily
basis
and time and cognitive capital are the
two most important things i think that a
person has
and i i just don't have the time in
cognitive capital to to conduct a
full-scale research project because
i'll be honest with you it takes it
takes weeks to research these projects
these papers it really is like a
academic research paper
and
that time spent could be spent
helping police organizations reduce
crime
or helping a student with their thesis
you know it's all about again it's all
about perspective but
it's just it's just a matter of time in
cognitive capital and it's not infinite
in my case
interesting okay that makes sense
that makes sense so you said when you
teach statistics
you use real real world examples try and
keep things interesting so it's not just
all math basically
okay
cool
i'll take that course then that's that's
cool that's good
that's good okay well
i ran through all my questions
vincent is there anything else you want
to talk about
that you think could be interesting
well i i um i am writing a paper i'm
working on a paper on um
sort of the the future of the west based
off of dating dynamics
and it was a conversation that i had
with chris williamson uh on his podcast
about
what the possible effect of of this
imbalance in the sexual marketplace
would be
and
chris and i sort of came to the
conclusion we sort of got to the point
where we said that
there are going to be significant
problems down the line where you have a
a large number of men who are without a
mate
and that does not bode well for a
society if you have a bunch of hapless
listless men
that are out there unmotivated
and
that has the potential to to completely
tear society apart
and so i think i think it's an important
idea an important talking point that we
need to be speaking more about as a
society
but you don't think there's a solution
i don't i think exactly that so it's
it's it i don't think that there's a
there's a straightforward solution i
think as i said it plays its way
uh the court it will play its way
through but at the same time it's
important to be very cognizant of these
of these
um potential problems this potential
problem because it still allows you to
set up barriers and
not potential solutions but sort of
buffer zones as it were
yeah
do you think it's going to get
significantly worse before it starts to
write itself significantly significantly
this is i think this is how a lot of
phenomena uh play themselves out is that
things typically get worse before they
get better is that we i don't think
we've we've reached the zenith of this
issue just quite yet
because if if you look in antiquity
there is a
0.71 correlation between
a sexual imbalance where there's more
men than women
and
um authoritarian regimes and it's
probably the case that a lot of these
men have a tendency of voting for
authoritarian regimes
but it's probably the case that the
reason why these authoritarian regimes
remain intact is because
they need to be able to keep these men
from committing violence
interesting yeah
wow okay that's cool do you think that's
why canada keeps voting for trudeau
i'm not sure just kidding
sure
and maybe nowadays too authoritarianism
looks a little different than it used to
yeah like
yeah
okay but that's the thing though is that
it's it's i'm sure people in the 1930s
in nazi germany thought the same way
where they said that you know it could
be just confiscation of houses it's not
quite jackfruits things can change very
quickly in a short period of time right
societies if you if you read a lot of
literature on societal collapse one of
the main things that becomes evident is
that civilizations are not permanent
right they're very they're very fallible
they're very frigid they're they're
rigid excuse me they're um they're not
rigid
they can break apart in a very short
period of time over a number of
generations and all that is required is
is a slow and inexorable decline
that's so scary i was just talking to my
dad about that too because i was like
things are i was like i i left canada
right and like things are
sketchy like they're implementing some
laws there that
are pretty overreaching and then this
thing with the truckers bank accounts
happen and it's just like
things are sketchy i was like is this
gonna is this really gonna get worse
and my dad made the point he was like
yeah well when hitler was in power like
not to do a direct comparison but things
just devolved in like a decade right to
a crazy point i was like
yikes you'd think that that wouldn't
necessarily happen again now that we
have that experience to look at
so hopefully it doesn't but
life's pretty weird right now yeah for
sure
for sure and i'd say that again you know
going back to the topic of societal
collapse is that i think what becomes
clear when you read a lot of this
literature is that
it's about the maintenance of
institutions so
if you can't if you're not if a society
is not able to pass on knowledge of how
to maintain institutions from one
generation to the next society is going
to fall apart and so you know the roman
empire a lot of studies were one one
ethographic analysis well it's not one
but it's quite a large study looked at
pottery in the roman empire and you can
see that the decline of the empire was
tracked by the sophistication and the
amount of pottery that was created by
the empire members of the empire and the
idea here is that they sort of lost the
knowledge over time they didn't have the
ability to create really beautiful
pieces of art and i think the same thing
applies to other institutions is that
the family if we want to think about it
as an institution has to remain intact
we have to be able to create new
successive generations that are that are
capable of engaging in the family unit
and as far as i can see we're not able
to do that we're not able to produce
children that
want to get married when they're older
want to be parents want to live in a in
a happy and healthy healthy healthy
family and
civilizations are built upon the backs
of healthy civilizations are built upon
the backs of healthy families and if you
don't have healthy families you don't
have a civilization
yeah
well
i hope things
reverse for a while rather than
continuing to devolve you just want to
see chaos
why
i'm like harry sheldon uh i i don't want
to see chaos but that'll probably be
what will happen more than likely i hope
it doesn't happen i hope i'm wrong i
hope i'm wrong
but
with the way things are shaping up i
don't i don't necessarily see a bright
future per se
i don't know how i feel about it i don't
feel very good about canada that's for
sure
i hope things reverse as well
oh well we will see we'll see okay
vincent are you anywhere online is there
anywhere i can direct people to go if
they want to follow okay you just you
just exist
podcast to podcast
i don't i don't really do social media
as i said there are no instagram stories
there's no tweets there's no facebook
posts
i think you gotta get not gonna share my
you're not gonna share my instagram
clips i'll get my friends to do it i'll
get it right nice okay he's pretty
popular he's a smart guy
great did you call james or a nerd
yeah he's a nerd yeah i'll say to his
face actually all the time like you're
such a nerd
he's like
thank you
did you
that's great okay well thank you very
much for coming on that was fun yeah
well absolutely i really appreciate the
invite michaela it was a great
conversation i hope we can do it again
we will for sure
[Music]
you